okay guys okay to play psychobabble him
with I met Donald Trump and I a big old
croc right here oh we're doing a mission
today called rajul or the Commonwealth
okay and um you know I think it's a main
class I hang out of pocket now who plays
when Christina there's way too many
question and then [ __ ] what's real
what's not all right let's see what's
gone down here i'll see what's going
down here hope you didn't running game
all right isn't it grounds detective
agency mmm is sick how many things i got
on right now make sure to turn up all
these guys show on map [ __ ] on local map
oh ok I want me to [ __ ] exit oh
that's girls ok
huh
hmm how the [ __ ] tight how the [ __ ] over
here so that's dude that's the steerer
Sorry Sorry strong he's gonna spawn here
anyway always does area [ __ ] here Jen
disgusting oh oh ok as does I got what
happened oh ok no I write wait I'm good
shape here there ok no
am I just like mentally challenged oh my
god I love this oh it's okay [ __ ]
dead how the [ __ ] is this thing taking
right why is it making me leave no I'm
not supposed to be here that's why
dead dead dead dead djent djent djent
intent intent then jumped into dan dan
exquisite sucked up this is elevator
that's the whole quest gonna be a great
video all right how [ __ ] far away are
we stuck in you I didn't going back and
forth like that great [ __ ] stock okay
chase sou go like a mile down so you're
okay I don't tell me go this way so [ __ ]
that I'm gonna go for that Detective
Agency thing know what the [ __ ] this is
all about she's hot as [ __ ] we was
shocking tats is
nice
it's behind that right yeah how the [ __ ]
did I get in there are Charles house
I'll get around detective good Valentine
detector ape and say cut god yeah having
here to send account I'm oh she's a hard
time [ __ ] Oh Nick another stray
coming in from the raid raid you're too
late office is closed it's a point I
know you must be busy you're right I'm
sorry I didn't mean to be rude but it
uh-huh I'll get her you know Nick was
working a case skinny Malone's gang had
kidnapped a young woman and he tracked
them down there's an old bulb down there
that they use as a base ight okay let's
go save this match let's draw the coop